bienvenue à tous bonjour emmanuel
bonjour emilie c'est parlement hebdo
votre rendez vous d'info du week-end
pour voir ou revoir tous les temps forts
de la semaine politique avec tout
d'abord bien sûr l'ambiance flonflons
feu d'artifice défilé autres garden
party du 14 juillet à 14 juillet un
pacte et non par la crise c'est ce que
nous verrons dans quelques instants plus
de magasins ouverts le dimanche dans
l'hexagone c'était l'autre grande
actualité de la semaine avec le vote par
les députés de la proposition de loi ump
ça passe nous verrons toujours aussi mal
à gauche et puis rien ne va plus une
nouvelle fois au parti socialiste c'est
la guerre ouverte entre martine aubry et
manuel valls
alors est-ce le conflit des anciens
contre les modernes natif de coacher
nous tenterons d'y répondre
tous viendront enfin sur la rentrée du
nouveau parlement européen les
eurodéputés élus le 7 juin dernier se
sont retrouvées à strasbourg et parmi
eux emmanuel notre invité un petit jeune
qui débute en politique voilà nouveau
député européen et nouveau venu en
politique effectivement robert rochefort
bonjour jours alors on vous le plus en
avance sur les entrées bas vous allez
nous parlait tout à l'heure de la
rentrée des classes auront vous
connaissez dans les médias c'est souvent
pour commenter l'actualité économique
parce que vous avez pendant près de 20
ans dirigé le credoc qu'est le centre de
recherche sur les conditions de vie des
français vous êtes un spécialiste toutes
les questions de consommation et puis
vous avez décidé de passer de l'autre
côté si je puis dire non plus seulement
du côté des experts mais des acteurs
politiques
début 2009 en rejoignant françois bayrou
pour conduire la liste du modem dans la
région sud ouest une nouvelle expérience
mais vous dites que on y reviendra que
françois bayrou portent les mêmes
valeurs que celles que vous défendez
c'était donc pour vous une semaine
chargée le tout début de cette nouvelle
carrière au parlement européen
on va la reprendre avec l'actualité de
la semaine mais en commençant par la
journée de lundi c'est d'abord le
feuilleton sarkozy l'épisode comment
j'ai voulu devenir président
et oui effectivement puisque l lundi on
découvre que nicolas sarkozy on le
savait a pensé à devenir président en se
rasant mais pas seulement
c'est également en regardant jacques
chaban-delmas que l'actuel chef de
l'état s'est mis un jour à croire en sa
bonne étoile
c'est ce qu'on a découvert lundi grâce à
une interview diffusée sur france 5
morceaux choisis c'était à boulogne pour
un meeting de jacques chaban-delmas que
je soutenais comme jeune garçon que
j'étais à l'époque et entrant dans cette
salle j'ai compris ce jour là que ce que
lui disait la tribune
je voulais en faire ma vie et vous aviez
déjà l'idée de devenir président de la
république à ce moment là je crains que
ce soir là l'idée m'était flore bon
alors nicolas sarkozy a voulu devenir
président en regardant jacques chaban
delmas
et vous vous avez voulu devenir
eurodéputé en regardant un jour françois
de l'aéro je vais vous raconter une
anecdote j'ai un fils qui quand il était
petit garçon disait je voudrais de
maître du monde
vous voyez je sais pas si le deviendra
non mais là ce qu'on vient de voir moi
je dois dire que j'étais quand même très
troublé parce que on nous donne un côté
que le président de l'udc ne va pas
répondre
le 14 juillet comme le faisaient ses
prédécesseurs au rituel du jeu des
questions et en revanche on a eu droit à
nouveau à une présence médiatique archi
forte avec cette idée de complicité de
souvenirs personnels ou bien l'interview
de carla bruni sarkozy
je trouve vraiment que il ya derrière
tout ça toute une stratégie de
communication extrêmement le guen
élaboré peut-être d'ailleurs n'est ce
pas sans rapport avec le courrier vient
de recevoir nicolas sarkozy de la part
de philippe séguin le premier président
de la cour des comptes qui lui dit qu'il
ya des dépenses de conseiller les agents
du corps du cas tout ça me semble je
pense que je veux simplement dire c'est
que pour moi le 14 juillet pour
l'ensemble des français
c'est une parenthèse importante où on
célèbre la communauté nationale ou en
même temps je crois en dessous d'un
politique se voit la ola ya toujours de
la politique est là le président innove
laurie il fait pas de la politique mais
il fait quand même de la politique tout
ça est certainement très que cette
admiration pour jacques chaban-delmas ça
vous étonne outre qu'une cohérence
écoutez je pense que quand on est quand
on est jeune et je ne conteste pas que
nicolas sarkozy ait cette vocation très
jeune on est évidemment intéressé par
leader du moment et je crois que jacques
chaban delmas dans les différents
leaders gaulliste de l'époque
représentait certainement le courant
humaniste le courant comment dit on de
certains faits social comme quand on a
entre 15 et 20 ans peut-être on est plus
attirée vers survient tout petit peu
avoue quand même qu'est ce qui vous a
fait vous décider à aller vers françois
bayrou alors vous n'étiez pas marqué
politiquement de façon très forte
non mais j'ai toujours été de ma famille
de pensée et centriste d'ailleurs quand
on étudie comme sales et les modes de
vie les phénomènes économiques et
sociaux on a quand même assez tendance à
essayer de comprendre vraiment le
fonctionnement des choses de ne pas
caricaturer en disant à ganac ont
complètement raison et d'autres
complètement tort avant après c'est une
façon de ne pas choisir non je crois que
c'est une façon d'essayer de se dire que
ce qui est le plus important c'est c'est
ce qui peut rassembler des gens au delà
d'une sorte de fracture partisane
définitive l'excentris françois bayrou
je croyais encore mesuré dans ses propos
je crois qu'il est plus que jamais
justement être centriste ce n'est pas
être comme ça a été pendant probablement
trop longtemps un allié systématique
d'un camp en ayant le sentiment qu'on
doit avaler toutes les couleuvres mais
moi j'ai quand même choisi de changer
parce qu'effectivement con pendant un
temps un peu plus vous avez regardé
comment ça se passe comme un observateur
comme une sorte de professeur nimbus
vous dites aussi ce qui est important
maintenant c'est de se trouver des
solutions face à la politique alors
enchaîné avec la journée de mardi vous
parlez du 14 juillet on va y revenir en
détail ce 14 juillet aux couleurs de
bollywood
et oui l'armée française au grand
complet mais également 400 soldats
indiens dans le défilé 5000 invités pour
la garden party de l'elysée la tour
eiffel illuminée par un feu d'artifice
historiques et même mêmes vous l'avez
dit une first lady carla bruni qui
accorde une interview exclusive à une
grande chaîne de télévision mardi donc
le 14 juillet 2009 a été célébré en
grande pompe même si la crise économique
était quand même là et bien là
en toile de fond tout de suite le compte
rendu des festivités avec juliette d'un
cran c'est une journée un signe
multiples pour le président qui se
refuse toujours à faire l'interview du
14 juillet premier mouvement un peu
avant 13 heures juste après le défilé ou
l'inde est à l'honneur
nicolas sarkozy accorde quelques mots
aux caméras de télévision avec un seul
message plus pédagogique politique
le budget de la défense sera maintenu
377 milliards d'euros somme considérable
sur les deux années qui viennent
on a besoin de deux professionnels
vraiment
maximum de leur technicité deuxième
épisode à l'elysée 5000 invités se
pressent dans les jardins du château
c'est 2000 de moins que l'an dernier
crise oblige mais ça fait quand même du
monde
en coulisses et en off claude guéant
reçoit les journalistes avec cet aveu le
secrétaire général de l'elysée confie
qu'il aimerait voir nicolas sarkozy se
représenter en 2012
c'est le deuxième temps de la
communication présidentielle
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais
d'abord bien sûr vous souhaiter la
bienvenue
les époux sarkozy se feront suite à
leurs invités cinq minutes montre en
main de bonnes foules avant de
s'éclipser dans les salons privés
soldats indiens ont à peine le temps de
prendre quelques photos
enfin troisième temps de la
communication élyséenne et pas des
moindres sur tf1 pour clore le 14
juillet c'est carla bruni qui parle à la
place du président vous savez il n'est
pas pressé il est il est habité par par
une obsession qui est de servir notre
pays et la première dame confie que le
bonheur apaise tous ces messages glisser
le long de la journée au lieu de la
traditionnelle interview
c'est une façon pour le chef de l'état
de saturer l'espace médiatique sans en
avoir l'air et de délivrer un message
pour lui jusqu'ici tout va bien
mon regard au choix quand on est un
responsable politique ce que vous êtes
désormais cette importance et grand
rituel républicain comme le 14 juillet
alors votre commentaire votre regard sur
ce cru 2009
écoutez alors si on met à part la
question de la communication
présidentielle dont on a évidemment déjà
parlé bon je pense que c'est très
important pour les français c'est un
moment où je crois la république a un
sens et en particulier ses valeurs
républicaines
le fait qu'il y ait encore au delà
d'abord ces présentations militaires
elles ont lieu dans toutes les
préfectures de france c'est à dire qu'il
ya pas que à paris cette façon d'être en
communion avec l'armée je pense que le
président de l'udc a raison de dire
qu'il faut soutenir l'armée je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être en tout cas moi
c'est ce que je souhaiterais mais vous
serez pas étonné que je vous le dise
qu'on aille aussi vers plus d'efforts
vers un corps européen d'art mais ça
existe un petit peu mais probablement
que ce n'est pas encore assez développé
parce que l'art mais ça n'a de sens que
pour nous prévenir de la guerre et ça
n'a de sens que sur une vision d'avenir
et sur une vision d'avenir on voit bien
là aussi qui a pas d'autre réponse
qu'une réponse européenne qu'est ce qui
change par rapport à l'ère chirac dans
la manière de célébrer lé 14 juillet ont
écouté je sais pas s'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui changent
je dirais que moi ce qui m'a frappé en
tout cas cette année c'est que on est
dans une crise économique absolument
majeur que les français on sent bien on
vit un petit peu là de retrouver un peu
d'optimisme parce que probablement que
la rentrée ça extrêmement difficile et
le 14 juillet la célébration la fête du
14 juillet est un élément sur lequel
nous les faut pas bouder en même temps
le nom de bouge pas et c'est quelque
chose qui est probablement rassurant est
intéressant c'est vers la trouve que
c'est aux salariés tait parce que la
crise la crise a été la suffisamment
attendu n'est pas sûr que le fait
d'avoir réduit le nombre d'invités à la
garden party soit significativement un
élément qui donne le sentiment que la
république fait des économies
en tout cas je pense pas que ce soit le
14 juillet qu'il aurait fallu faire une
fête austère sous prétexte relais dans
la crise ivoirienne en vous vous étiez
ou pour ce 14 juillet fiction georges
heures et mettait la garden party parce
que le président m'avait invité mais je
travaillais parce que figurez-vous que
le 14 juillet c'était justement et
solennelle de rentrée et vous compreniez
bien que dans un parlement avec vingt
sept nationalités
si on devait fêter les fêtes nationales
de chacun des 27 pays on travaillerait
quasiment jamais jour férié pour les
parisiens ce coussin il ya la fête de
l'europe
le 9 mai mais à part ça les jours comme
une étoile à les jours fériés nationaux
ne peuvent évidemment pas être repris
tous dans leur intégralité 1er janvier a
ajouté oui parce que le parlement est
effectivement fermé pendant deux semaine
entre noël et les fêtes de la nouvelle
année alors le jour de l'an donc
l'occasion pour les français de
rencontrer le 14 juillet par d'ange
mangement mêle aussi l'occasion pour les
français de rencontrer leurs armes et
cette semaine était d'ailleurs marqué au
sénat par l'examen de la loi de
programmation militaire pour qui couvre
la période 2009 2014 une armée vous
l'avez entendu dans le chef de l'état
assure qu'elle ne va pas pâtir de la
crise économique mais s'il n'y a pas de
sacrifice pour les équipements la
défense n'échappe pas aux compressions
d'effectifs le détail avec pierre bande
joseph où va l'armée premier élément de
réponse elle devra fonctionner avec
moins d'effectifs la loi de
programmation militaire prévoit la
suppression de 54 mille postes sur cinq
ans essentiellement des forces de
soutien et logistique
une diminution qui n'est pas sans
conséquence sur ses capacités
d'intervention
on a renforcé le nombre de soldats en
afghanistan il y a quelques mois on a dû
réduire notre présence dans certaines
opérations extérieures
et effectivement on peut se trouver en
cours de route avec des problèmes
d'un manque d'effectif l'état promet
pourtant un effort financier
exceptionnel en portant l'investissement
à 18 milliards d'euros par an mais
lorsque l'on analyse des chiffres plus
précisément la part du pib consacrée à
l'effort de défense baisse passant de
2,3 pour cent du pib aujourd'hui à 2%
dans les années qui viennent
l'armée devra donc trouver de nouvelles
ressources financières propres comme le
souligne la loi de programmation
militaire
il ya là une réduction des implantations
une réduction du nombre d'élus du
personnel et une externalisation d'un
certain nombre d'activités par exemple
des choses qu'on fait à l'intérieur de
l'armée
l'entretien qui peuvent être à
l'extérieur par des sociétés privées on
multiplie également le partenariat
public-privé l'armée en temps de crise
c'est aussi une armée qui donne la
priorité à ce service de renseignement
permettant d'intervenir au plus tôt et
de déclencher les opérations qu en
dernière limite
voilà donc tandis qu'à paris en fait tu
as dignement le 14 juillet à strasbourg
vous l'avais dit c'était plutôt ambiance
rentrée des classes les 732 euros
députés élus le 7 juin dernier dont
robert rochefort ont donc pris place
dans l'hémicycle pour élire jerzey buzek
le polonais ex solidarnosc qu'il est
désormais le nouveau président du
parlement européen tout de suite julien
jacquet revient pour nous sur cette
journée pas comme les autres un européen
de l'est élu à la tête du parlement
c'est une première pour l'union
européenne jay-z buzek ancien premier
ministre polonais a été adoubé hier à
une très large majorité des voix
le vote a eu lieu lors de la session
constitutive du parlement issu des
élections de juin
âgé de 69 ans jazzy buzek était le
candidat du parti conservateur
il est élu pour deux ans et demi en
vertu de l'accord passé entre les
groupes du parlement
nos citoyens ne comprennent pas vraiment
ce qui se passe dans l'union européenne
dans quelle direction nous allons et
l'importance de ce que nous réalisons
dans ce parlement européen nous devons
rester proche d'eux nous devons
également être en contact étroit avec
les parlements nationaux
cette élection a valeur de symbole 20
ans tout juste après la chute du régime
communiste en pologne et cinq ans après
l'élargissement de l'union européenne à
l'est
c'est une joie pour tous le parlement la
première fois dans ce parlement
nous n'avons plus d'europe de l'est et
de l'ouest
nous avons simplement une europe par le
symbole de notre président est à la
tribune
aujourd'hui la session constitutive du
parlement européen se poursuit jusqu'à
la fin de la semaine
l'autre dossier important pour les
eurodéputés c'est la confirmation ou non
de josé manuel barroso à la tête de la
commission européenne
faute d'accord entre les groupes la
décision a été reportée en septembre
prochain
quant à rochefort avant de parler de
barros oh bien sûr et de jardy buzek ont
envie de vous poser une question
personnelle qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti quand vous êtes arrivé à
strasbourg que vous avez pris place dans
cet hémicycle et que finalement une
nouvelle page de votre existence est
ouvert alors je vais vous dire des
banalités mais on souhaite évidemment il
est chargé les fortes il ya une émotion
très grande
ce qui est important quand même c'est
que tous ses députés sont vraiment les
élus du peuple enfin dans les trois
institutions européennes le parlement
européen c'est vraiment le peuple c'est
à dire c'est vraiment ces 500 millions
d'européens et là il ya quelque chose
qui est extraordinairement important je
crois que malheureusement on constate
aussi ensuite très vite comment même
avec toute l'énergie qui a là ça va être
difficile parce que il ya tant de
cultures tang langue dans l'histoire 36
et sauro député cinquantaine de moins
que dans le précédent parlement la
complexité que ça représente on sent à
la fois ci si on met à part quelques
dizaines d'anti européen qui ont été
élus là parce que ça représente une
petite partie de l'opinion mais si on
met à part cela et qui sont d'ailleurs
sont facilement huer par l'ensemble
des députés on sent à la fois l'énergie
le bleu le désir d'y aller et en même
temps le fait que ça va être à ce point
si difficile parce que quand on se parle
on fait écho à des as des as des siècles
finalement d' approche qui sont comment
dire extrêmement différent de comprenait
entre des entre des peuples qui ont
encore besoin d'accéder au progrès et au
développement c'est le cas d'un certain
nombre des pays de l'union et d'autres
qui se demandent comment sortir de la
crise en inventant une société qui soit
plus une société du gaspillage de la
surconsommation mais au contraire de l'
équilibre de la mesure de quelque chose
d'un peu plus qualitatif
on voit bien comment les écarts on voit
aussi comment par exemple moi je suis un
démocrate et et nous nous sommes pour
une économie de marché n'est pas une
société libérale au sens de tout ça peut
représenter
et quand vous avez des collègues qui
effectivement ont été jusqu'à une
vingtaine d'années dans une économie
complètement administrés mais ils ont du
mal à comprendre l'idée que vous pouvez
formuler qui est de dire que la société
libérale n'est pas l'idéal vers lequel
il faut aller mais mais encore une fois
voilà c'est tout ça tout ça converge
m'étais dit que ça en place d'un parti
comme le vôtre dans ce parlement perde
ce que je dis quand même ce paradoxe que
vous arrivez au moment où françois
bayrou lui-même porteur du message
européen vient de se prendre la pire
claque politique de sa carrière oui
alors c'est vrai qu' on est six députés
du modem je ne vous cache pas qu'on
aurait aimé être un petit peu plus
nombreux mais mais nous sommes au sein
d'un groupe qui s'appelle l'alliance des
démocrates et des libéraux européens et
est ce groupe est composé d'un peu plus
de 80 députés et nous sommes le
troisième groupe parlementaire et il est
animé par guy verhofstadt qui est
l'ancien premier ministre belge qui a
une très grande expérience et un très
grand talent et une puissance comment
dire d'expression qui est absolument
incontestable donc on se dit en même
temps que c'est au sein de cette famille
politique troisième groupe et qu'on va
pouvoir faire des choses parce que le
parlement européen comme c'est un
parlement qui est élu à la
proportionnelle dans tous les pays et
bien finalement
même lorsqu'il est très à droite comme
c'est le cas parce que c'est la
conséquence du résultat des élections la
droite ne peut pas à elle toute seule
tout faire
tour du doubs s'est mise de la recherche
permanente de trouver une bonne réponse
en associant des gens qui sont au point
de départ issus de familles politiques
différentes
alors on va revenir sur des aspects plus
politiques dans un instant on va
regarder tout de suite le parcours d'une
de vos collègues au parlement européen
vous savez qu'il ya eu comme ça un
certain nombre de figures sur lesquels
les médias en france notamment se sont
beaucoup penché on parle de rachida dati
mais il ya aussi karima delli qu est la
benjamine des eurodéputés français aient
la stap une élue surprise 1 grâce au bon
score des verts en fin de la liste
europe écologie conduite par daniel cohn
bendit puisqu'elle était l'une des
candidates dans la région ile de france
voici donc sa journée est suivi par
l'esp rayssac à la voiture bar c'est
elle la star bien malgré elle dans le
train direction strasbourg de nombreux
députés européens
mais ce jour là ce n'est pas rachida
dati mais karima delli qui intéresse les
journalistes je les invite à
s'intéresser siem et collègues
c'est important aussi on est une équipe
toujours penser collectif le credo de
karima delli militant au sein de jeudi
noir pour la réquisition de logements
vides elles participent également au
mouvement sauvons les riches qui défend
un salaire maximum en europe
cet esprit contestataire franchi avec
elle le seuil du parlement à peine
arrivée la jeune écologiste de 30 ans
affiche la couleur
là on est en train se dire allez on fait
un front une grande alliance fou une
alternative à bord au zoo donc c'est
peut-être possible alors on le fait
premiers pas dans la cour européenne les
premières formalités administratives un
badge et un bureau pour cinq ans il ne
reste plus qu à le trouver et à prendre
ses marques
un univers qui ne lui est pas si
étranger assistante de la sénatrice
marie christine blandin depuis cinq ans
elle quitte une assemblée pour une autre
plus imposante
tu es notre phase de ma vie c'est très
bien c'est enrichissant mais et voilà
c'est nouveau et j'appréhende un peu au
fait il lui reste maintenant à trouver
sa place au sein d'un groupe au leader
charismatique
c'est bien parti elle a obtenu les
missions qu'elle voulait le
développement régional l'emploi et les
affaires sociales
la place en groupe elle est là aussi
c'est à dire de faire avancer les idées
du groupe
par mon intermédiaire donc sachant que
flatter plutôt contente
voilà à la pause déjeuner pas de répit
karima delli par soutenir les
producteurs de lait qui manifestent à
proximité du parlement une jambe dans
l'institution une autre dans le
mouvement social
elle tient à maintenir cet équilibre son
équilibre on relève entendu robert
rochefort est un objectif pour karima
delli et ses amis d'europe écologie ce
qui est de rendre plus difficile qu'on
la pensait au début
l'élection du nouveau président de la
désignation et si monsieur barroso n'a
pas été reconduit dès la session de
juillet c'est aussi par la position que
le groupe auquel j'appartiens
alors finalement c'est essayer de
regarder nous avons d'abord monsieur
barroso revient j'allais dire en
deuxième semaine puisqu'il va se
présenter un ou début du mois de
septembre avec son désir d'être
effectivement désigné je vais reconduit
à la mi septembre
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est le
fond des choses nous avons entendu
monsieur barroso il est venu à
strasbourg et et finalement quand nous
lui disons nous voulons vraiment une
europe forte à une commission qu'ils
soient leaders qui qui qui aie par
exemple avec un implant unique de lutte
contre la crise monsieur barroso nous
dit je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous mais qu'est ce que vous voulez les
différents pays membres sont pas très
partant beaucoup frêne est en fait ce
que nous aimerions c'est avoir un
président de la commission un peu comme
l'avait été jacques delors il ya
quelques temps quelques années c'est
requis qui essaye d'aller plus loin
l'europe vous savez si l'europe on s'en
tient toujours aux lourdeurs au fait
qu'il y en a un qui veut pas qu'il y en
a un deuxième qui est hésitant on arrive
pas on fait le plus petit commun
dénominateur ce que je voudrais besoin
c'est quelqu'un qui aille plus loin qui
transfère sa et ben écoutez je ne sais
pas si ça fait partie de la personnalité
de monsieur barroso je suis pas je suis
pas complètement sûr c'est
non plus vous allez lui un président du
parlement qui est symboliquement un
personnage très fort d'après ses
premières déclarations il ne semble pas
non plus c'est un peu là c'est un peu le
même type de questions
simplement le président de la commission
a incontestablement un rôle de
proposition plus fort que le président
du parlement le président du parlement
ils organisent les débats au parlement
après c'est au parlement effectivement
d'avoir aussi cette capacité dans la co
décision et je l'espère avec le traité
de lisbonne si effectivement il est
définitivement ratifié avec le
référendum irlandais qui va avoir lieu
dans quelques semaines voilà il faut il
faut aller plus loin il faut être plus
fort et c'est pour ça que nous monsieur
barroso on a envie de lui dire passer la
main à quelqu'un qui soit beaucoup plus
punchy qui soit capable de transcender
ces résistances europe et une nouvelle
ère elle est en maintenant refermer ce
volet européen revenaient avec nous en
france et à l'assemblée nationale robert
rochefort on part on se passe à la
journée de mercredi les députés en
finisse enfin avec la bagarre sur le
travail dominical
est ce une régression du droit social ou
une nouvelle souplesse bénéfique l
intérêt général quelles sont les zones
où désormais les magasins seront ouverts
le dimanche comment seront rémunérés
aussi ses salariés du septième jour
mercredi c'est donc jour de vote à
l'assemblée pour le texte sur le travail
dominical la gauche vous allez le voir
est toujours vent debout et une partie
de la droite il va aussi toujours à
reculons tout de suite retour sur un
texte complexe et pas franchement
consensuelle avec julian d'un camp pour
281 2 contre 238
l'assemblée nationale a adopté après
ciseaux et demi de bataille
parlementaire et plus de 50 heures de
débat
ça y est les députés ont enfin adopté la
proposition de loi qui autorise le
travail du dimanche sur ce texte les
députés socialistes ont trouvé la faille
la proposition concernerait selon eux
plusieurs milliers de communes
allez vous enfin nous dire que comme
nous vous le disons et ce depuis huit
jours ce ne sont pas 500 communes
concernées allez-vous c'est celle
embrouilles et retirer votre texte pour
clarifier ce point un amendement précise
que le texte s'appliquera aux communes
d'intérêt touristique et n'ont pas
d'influencé touristique
mais dans ce cas les contreparties
financières ne seront pas obligatoires
mais devront être négocié avec les
syndicats pour faire voter le texte la
majorité a fait une deuxième concession
il n'y a qu'au parti socialiste qu'on ne
sait pas que la nouvelle loi
grâce aux périmètres d'usagé de
consommation exceptionnel va apporter
des garanties nouvelles aux salariés
si vous ne voulez pas dire les pets
c'est votre droit mais nous nous le
voterons ce concerner les grandes villes
comme paris lille ou marseille et dans
ce cas le travail du dimanche impliquera
le doublement du salaire et un repos
compensateur pas assez clair pour les
socialistes ils ont d'ores et déjà
prévenu qu'ils allaient saisir le
conseil constitutionnel
more marche pas reprenez votre casquette
credoc un petit moment le travail le
dimanche c'est bon pour la consommation
c'est surtout mauvais pour droit social
on en attendait surtout dans une période
de crise comme celle que nous
connaissons on sait bien que
on va pas consommer plus parce que les
magasins soient ouverts le dimanche non
je suis très content cette proposition
parce que il ya 2 il ya deux hypothèses
sossou selon les choses très simplement
ou bien c'est comme le dit le
gouvernement
quelques communes pas beaucoup de
communes et dans ces cas là on est dans
un débat de nature symbolique et c'est
très important parce que ça veut dire
est ce qu on veut que le dimanche soit
finalement considéré comme un jour
banaliser ou est ce que l'on veut que le
dimanche reste un jour on a quelque
chose de plus intéressant la finale je
dis un grand bravo d'ici là si la gauche
a raison je pense qu'elle a peut-être
raison parce que moi je peux vous dire
depuis 20 ans que l'on voit c'est en
permanence des désirs d'extension
supplémentaire des dérogations c'est à
dire que je suis pas surtout sur la fin
de l'histoire
il est tout à fait possible que dans un
an dans deux ans dans trois ans on nous
explique à nouveau qu'ils aient besoin
de faire d'erreur vous savez comment ça
se passe c'est très simple il ya des
commerces qui ouvrent tout seul sans en
avoir le droit
il crée une activité il embauche
forcément puisqu'à côté les commerces
sont fermés
donc évidemment eux ils attirent des
gens ça veut pas dire qu'il ya des
créations nettes d'emplois c'est pas il
peut y avoir des suppressions d'emplois
dans les commerces qui sont lésés et
puis ces commerces fonctionnent pendant
un an
pendant deux ans dans l'illégalité et
après on nous dit faut régulariser
on va quand même pas remettre maintenant
au chômage tous ceux qui les ont un
texte qui actent une situation de fait
ou c'est une usine à gaz comme de la
gauche non je pense que c'est une étape
de plus vers une augmentation du nombre
de dérogations il y en a à peu près déjà
300 cas en france celle usine à gaz
existait avant ce texte
elle est renforcée avec ce texte et il
ya le risque que on invente une
tuyauterie de plus dans deux ans dans
trois ans je pense donc que c'est pas
une bonne affaire
quant aux salariés qui peut croire
aujourd'hui dans la période de crise
nous sommes que ceux qui vont avoir des
contrats de travail on leur dit vous
n'êtes pas obligés de travailler le
dimanche ne signait pas ce contrat de
travail si vous voulez pas le faire qui
va croire réellement que le salarié qui
est vraiment besoin de nourrir sa
famille pourra choisir librement aller
un autre débat qui concerne tous les
français c'est celui sur les tarifs de
l'électricité
la demande du président d'edf pierre
gadonneix qs d'une hausse de 20% sur
trois ans continue de faire des vagues
gouvernement et à ses critiques sur la
forme mais n'exclut pas une augmentation
dans son dans le principe et notamment
parce qu'il s'agit de financer
l'entretien du parc de centrales
nucléaires français alors pierre
gadonneix est justement était entendue
cette semaine mercredi à huis clos par
les députés de la commission des
affaires sociales écoutez tout de suite
la réaction du président de la
commission l'ump patrick ollier le seul
gars d'alex expliqué qu' il y avait un
prix d'interprétation il a indiqué qu'il
est disait que par rapport à la
maintenance du parc électrique français
notamment nucléaires il fait il avait un
besoin d'investissements pour maintenir
en état ce parc qui équivalait à une
augmentation de ce qui serait
souhaitable entre le souhaitable et
réalisable
il ya toute la différence que la
commission appréciera il n'est pas
normal que les augmentations si brutale
puisse gêner le consommateur donc on va
trouver le bon moyen de faire en sorte
recommandations du niveau de l'inflation
par exemple puissent faire l'objet d'une
réévaluation mais en aucun cas le double
de l'inflation sur une période aussi
courte de trois ans voilà et tout ça
bien sûr devant la commission des
affaires économique robert rochefort est
ce que le patron de d'électricité de
france a commis une faute de
communication sur nous ah non il a il a
avancé ses pions on est dans une logique
de marchandage
il tire très fort pour espérer obtenir
quelque chose
on est dans un jeu de rôle où
effectivement on pourra dire que
finalement lui donnant quelques pour
cent d'augmentation il est battu alors
qu'en fait il aura obtenu quelque chose
mais attendez vous voyez bien les
français n'y comprennent rien quand on
leur dit on baisse le taux du livret a
on leur dit a plus d'inflation on leur
dit même les prix sont en train de
diminuer 0,5 pour cent en une année et
en même temps on leur dit le tarif
d'électricité va augmenter de sommation
petit d'étiquettes une consommation
quotidienne
et même si l'entretien des centrales
nucléaires c'est essentiel mais je vais
vous dire quelque chose je suis pour que
les centrales nucléaires en france même
si je pense qu'il doit pas y avoir que
le nucléaire comme show électrique
je suis pour que les centrales
nucléaires ça reste de géré par une
entreprise nationale comme edf il s'agit
de prendre ces questions vraiment très
au sérieux
mais de là à effectivement balancer ses
20% de hausse sur quelques années bon
je crois que je crois que j'espère en
tout cas que évidemment se sera pas fait
que le gouvernement ne donnera pas son
accord à cette augmentation
allez on passe maintenant à la journée
de jeudi rue de solferino cette fois on
sort les couteaux jeudi il était une
fois une petite lettre écrite par une
femme à un homme et qui ne ressemblait
pas franchement à une lettre d'amour
martine aubry n'en peut plus que le
jeune manuel valls critique en
permanence sa gestion et son parti alors
à lui fait passer un message extrêmement
clair tu te tais ou tu t'en vas
de quoi exacerber les tensions latentes
depuis un moment et ouvrir plus
franchement encore la guerre des
tranchées au ps hélène mandroux mardi au
ps il fait partie de ceux qui donnent de
la voix
sauf que souvent c'est pour critiquer
son propre parti martine aubry elle en a
assez alors elle a réagi par la manière
forte et lui demande de s'arrêter ce
tout est dans la lettre je vous invite à
lire la lettre
en substance la chef du ps lui dit si tu
es propos reflètent à penser tu dois en
tirer les conséquences et quitter le
parti
anne ultimatum auquel manuel valls eux
répondent par une lettre lui aussi je
resterai fidèle à mon poste et à ma
famille politique
il précise qu'il entend bien garder sa
liberté de parole
quel qu'en soit le prix pour ses
soutiens la direction tente
maladroitement d'étouffer ses ambitions
on a un phénomène de crise passe une
crispation qui révèle vraiment une
faiblesse de la direction et c'est même
un petit peu pathétique d'en arriver à
ce genre de courrier
si elle veut envoyer des lettres tous
les gens du parti socialiste qui ne
pensent pas comme elle
ça va faire beaucoup d'après l'entourage
de martine aubry elle voudrait faire de
cette lettre un exemple pour les autres
quadras du ps comme arnaud montebourg
c'est un acte d'autorité de martine
aubry je trouve que c'est un acte
d'autorité attendu salutaire et on ne
montre pas du doigt effectivement une
personnalité parce qu'elle est riche
effectivement cette personnalité mais un
comportement
le combat entre manuel valls et martine
aubry ne fait que commencer
le quadra n'a pas l'intention de se
taire il va continuer à militer au sein
du parti pour combattre ce qu'il appelle
la conception daté de martine aubry
bon qu'est ce qui est pire aujourd'hui
être socialiste ou être modem
écoutez non je pense que cela est
certainement d'être socialiste c'est pas
à moi de porter un jugement sur les
affaires internes du parti socialiste je
crois néanmoins que manuel valls pose
des vraies questions qui aujourd'hui
peut penser qu'ils ne posent pas des
vraies questions et je pense que les à
la fois les militants socialistes comme
l'opinion doit être très étonné par le
fait que y ait ce débat public cet
échange de correspondance qui montre que
la crise est très très grave
mais vous savez moi je vais vous dire au
modem pas plus qu'ailleurs je crois on
n'a pas intérêt à voir un parti
socialiste aussi des structures est
aussi faible
on s'est dit qu'en ce qui est plutôt pas
mal pour fins à bao chau je crois pas je
crois que je crois qu'il faut une vie
politique dans laquelle il y ait une
gauche kelly à une droite dans laquelle
il y un centre qui représente ce qui
l'est c'est pour ça que je suis tout
autant critique par rapport à la
politique d'ouverture de nicolas sarkozy
que de me satisfaire d'une sorte de 2,2
de gauche ont demandé composition lancé
my way s'attendrait plutôt mieux avec la
jeune garde ou d'anciennes heures de
nage une garde à vous entendre
écoutez moi je sus que ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que dans un certain
nombre d'élections locales
il y a effectivement des alliances entre
le ps et le modem ça ne correspond pas
du tout à une politique nationale
il arrive que ceux qui dénoncent ces
alliances au niveau national soit tout à
fait contents de les faire vivre
au niveau local je crois qu'il ya je
crois qu'il ya un grand jeu de rôle si
vous voulez mon va se décider il voulait
si vous voulez mon avis tout va dépendre
de l'évolution des rapports de force je
pense que le modem
cette fois ci a fait un score plus
faible que son poids effectif je pense
donc qu'il sera amené à remonter et je
pense qu'à ce moment-là l'intérieur du
parti socialiste le débat entre ceux qui
disent non jamais le modem ou ceux qui
disent avec le modem s'estompera un
petit peu et que le bon sens consistera
regarder les rapports de forces est
peut-être arrivé dans des logiques de de
commandes entièrement de s'opposer
ensemble
bien que il faille pas du tout
considérer que c'est l'étape est déjà
venue de l'annoncé mais mais en tout cas
si vous voulez une réponse je me sens
plus proche effectivement des analyses
de manuel valls que des analyses de
martine aubry ça c'est clair
jusqu'où va descendre le taux du livret
à vous y faisiez allusion il ya quelques
instants il doit être revus le 1er août
la décision du gouvernement est tombé
jeudi il va passer de 1 75 à 1 25%
s'il fallait tenir compte d'ailleurs
exactement de l'inflation il serait aux
alentours de 0,25 mais l'elysée a
souhaité amortir le choc est préservée
l'epargne populaire explications de la
ministre de l'économie christine lagarde
au micro d' anne louise d'oran j'ai
décidé de le maintenir à 1,25 pour cent
car je considère qu'il est légitime de
rémunérer l'épargné
c'est sur le livret à qui est un produit
d'épargné populaire qui permet de verser
de retirer de l'argent de manière
totalement libre et défiscalisées vous
voyez c'est une mesure d'amélioration
par rapport à une formule mathématique
qui redonnait un taux trop bas alors pas
d' application de la formule
mathématique mais une sorte de coup de
pouce politique
le gouvernement a raison d'être très
prudents sur le taux de ce livret a au
moment où on enregistre déjà réalisé
collecté était si j'avais dû prendre
cette décision je vais vous dire ce que
j'aurais proposé qu'on fasse j'aurais
proposé qu'on reste 1,75 quitte à ce que
ce soit pour une partie simplement du
livret a c'est à dire pas jusqu'au
plafond des 15000 euros
mais peut-être pour les 5000 premiers
euros parce que c'était populaire oui
c'était certes arctique est vraiment
extrêmement populaire c'est ça qui est
important
je crains qu'aujourd'hui avec 1,25 pour
cent
beaucoup de gens se disent il n'y a plus
aucune rémunération c'est ce sont des
clopinettes
et puis les gens se disent dans trois
mois ça va redescendre alors à 1% et
puis à 0,75 pour cent
et puis il ya une autre question
importante parce qu'on nous dit les taux
baissent normal que livrer la baisse
mais je sais pas si vous êtes allé
demander un emprunt à votre banque si
vous franchissez la porte d'une agence
bancaire aujourd'hui et que vous dites
j'ai besoin d'emprunter
certes on va vous dire les taux n'ont
jamais été aussi bas mais qu'est ce
qu'on va vous proposer comme tôt on va
vous proposer du 5%
on va vous proposer même plus que ça si
c'est un un crédit à la consommation
ponctuelle
donc effectivement on voit bien que pour
ce qui est de la vie concrète des gens
on est un petit peu loin de cette idée
consistant à dire qu'il n'ya plus aucune
inflation et on vous fait un cadeau on
vous le m'étendre impose de ne pas trop
encourager l'épargné au contraire
justement de dire aux gens malsains
semaine c'est pour ça que je vous dis
que le laisser ce taux sur un seuil qui
aurait pu être par exemple un seuil de
5000 euros
ça n'était pas quelque chose qui
soustrait de l'argent la consommation
mais qui donnait tout de même aux
personnes comment dire les moins à
l'aise financièrement
l'idée que leur épargne la leur
rapportait quand même quelque chose je
pense que c'était peut-être une façon de
faire intervenir la notion de justice
sociale la notion d'intérêt comment dire
pour les plus les plus démunis mais qui
ont quand même un petit livret de caisse
d'epargne je crois que ça aurait valu le
coup de deux de faire un si elle est
toujours au chapitre à économie est
toujours jeudi une première historique
depuis louis seize personnes avaient mis
son nez dans les comptes des monarques
et autres présidents de la république
cette année la cour des comptes s'est
enfin intéressé à l'elysée en accord
bien sûr avec l'actuel chef de l'état
le constat vous allez le voir est plutôt
indulgent encore des efforts à faire
même si c'est déjà beaucoup mieux les
explications tout de suite avec anaïs
goût battions les services de la
présidence passée au crible par la cour
des comptes
une grande première et un bilan plutôt
positif que 18 et ce sont 18 ans les
habitudes
il est normal que tout se remette pas en
place ne se met pas en place du jour
du jour au lendemain c'est le premier
vrai budget de l'elysée on va il ya des
choses des habitudes qui sont pas encore
prise
iliad il ya les personnels à l'elysée
qui depuis 30 ans 40 ans procéder
différemment
donc il y à il ya une sorte de choc
culturel
avec un budget de 110 millions d'euros
en 2008 l'elysée doit encore faire des
efforts notamment en termes d'économies
et de marchés publics et deux jours
après la traditionnelle garden-party la
cour des comptes pointe du doigt le
manque d' appels d'offres à la
concurrence en ce qui concerne les
commandes de nourriture l'organisation
d'une telle réception nous sommes que vu
la différence de prix ont pour l an
prochain
être plus attentifs et tenté de varier
de varier la fourniture ne serait ce que
parce que le simple fait de l'envisager
conduit le fournisseur attitré à à ne
pas vivre sur ses lauriers sur ses prix
habituel comme le boucher pour la
première fois en 2008 l'elysée dispose
d'un budget unique
auparavant beaucoup de ces dépenses
étaient en fait payés par différents
ministères
bon alors moins d'opacité plus de
transparence et quand même de gros
correctifs à apporter dit philippe
seguin même si le dit avec le sourire
une fois n'est pas coutume notamment sur
les appels d'offres parce que voyez
d'autres sujets d'autres termes
activement la lettre de philippe séguin
et je dois vous dire que j'ai découvert
quelque chose qui m'inquiète énormément
c'est ce qui correspond au financement
qui est explicitée dans cette lettre de
sondages d'opinion par l'elysée publié
dans la presse y fait référence par
exemple à 35 études il est fait
référence à un sondage publié tous les
quinze jours en omnibus comme on dit par
un grand quotidien national et par
également une chaîne de télévision dans
lesquelles la cour des comptes dit et je
vous lis juste la phrase 400000 euros
facturés à la présidence pour la
participation à ces enquêtes dont la
comparaison des résultats publiés dans
la presse et ceux remis à la présidence
ne faisait pas apparaître de différence
on pouvait dès lors s'interroger sur
l'utilité de ces dépenses est ce que
cela veut dire et c'est comme ça que je
le lis qu'il ya des organes de presse
qui se font financer les enquêtes
d'opinion par la présidence de la
république sans que ce soit indiqué
lorsqu'on lit ses journaux et évidemment
je vous laisse ensuite envisager ce que
ça veut dire sur l'indépendance ou la
non indépendance et croyez moi j'ai été
professionnel dans sa baraque
exportations le démon et j'ai été
impressionné de cela extrêmement
longtemps et je sais dans ces cas là que
la façon de mettre une virgule de mettre
un adjectif de mettre un adverbe dans
une question a une certaine importance
alors moi j'ai lu le courrier de
philippe séguin
je pense que le premier président de la
cour des comptes qu'il peut pas être
taxé d'être un opposant majeure au
président rick n'a pas écrit ça par
hasard et je dois vous dire que ça me
préoccupe beaucoup mais c'était en suède
dans trois centres parler dans les
prochains jours en attendant dernier
jour de la semaine
vendredi et ça commence furieusement à
sentir les vacances du côté du sénat
c'est là qu'il travaillera encore la
semaine prochaine notamment justement
sur la question du travail dominical
mais tout de même c'est l'heure du bilan
pour l'année parlementaire tous les
records ont été battus 950 eur et 124
jours de séance selon le président
gérard larcher le président du sénat la
haute assemblée a réussi à imposer sa
marque et c'est l'occasion pour nous de
revenir sur la réforme de la
constitution qui devait alléger et
simplifier le travail parlementaire cinq
mois après sa mise en place le résultat
n'est pas encore à la hauteur des
objectifs affichés marie brémaud
accorder plus de place au travail
législatif effectué en commission
c'était un des points phares de la
réforme constitutionnelle les textes de
loi sont donc désormais débattue au sein
des commissions avant leur passage dans
l'hémicycle il est à droite comme à
gauche les sénateurs semblent fatigués
par la double tâche le travail en
commission il se fait je ne nie pas mais
il s'est alourdi considérablement
puisque tout se passe pratiquement en
double à la fois en commission il ya la
fois en séance - si j'ai un regret dans
cette affaire c'est qu'on recommence et
même discussion en séance
moi je trouve qu'il faudrait que des
discussions aient lieu et que les
discussions aient lieu
une fois pour toutes en commission des
discussions au sein des commissions qui
ont lieu en présence des ministres
concernés ministre également présents
sur les bancs de l'hémicycle
si ça devait se révéler être un doublon
alors ce serait qu'une partie de la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme n'aurait pas
marché et il faudrait à ce moment là
essayez de s'intéresser pour redresser
la barre au bout de cinq mois il est
encore un peu tôt pour tirer un bilan
définitif mais déjà certains ajustements
semble nécessaire comment vous regardez
sujet vous qui peut-être découvrez
justement les arcanes au parlement
européen la complexité de l'articulation
entre les commissions l'hémicycle alors
je me dis que au parlement européen est
quelque chose que manifestement on sait
faire et que peut-être nos collègues
des parlements nationaux non savent pas
peut-être encore complètement faire
c'est quand on est devant ce type de
difficulté vous savez au parlement
européen on a pour part les deux minutes
en 3 minutes ou parfois même simplement
une minute et il faut donc être capable
de concentrer pendant ces arguments
d'aller directement au but est
finalement peut-être qu'il faut être
capable parce que je trouve que c'est
pas mal d'avoir un débat à la fois en
commission et et un débat en plénière
simplement il faut peut-être à ce moment
là qu'on apprenne à être beaucoup plus
rassemblés dans ce que l'on veut dire on
a peut-être encore des progrès à faire
à cet égard dans l'est par lés deux les
deux assemblées française mais peut-être
aussi dans d'autres parlements nationaux
bien bon courage en tout cas pour cette
nouvelle et j'espère on parlera en terre
et j'espère en tout cas contre le
parlement européen et les parlements
nationaux
il y aura davantage de relations
davantage de possibilités de travailler
ensemble parce que sinon je crois que
les citoyens ne peuvent pas comprendre
grand chose contre iv merci se retrouver
la semaine prochaine
oui pour tirer le bilan cette fois
définitif de l'ensemble de cette session
avec le président du groupe nouveau
centre à l'assemblée nationale le député
françois sauvadet ce sera la der des der
de la saison à la semaine prochaine
convoqué massivement les criminels du
génocide devant la justice c'est le rôle
des gacacas ces tribunaux rwandais qui
rassemble victimes et bourreaux rwanda
les collines parle c'est votre
rendez-vous documentaire ce soir à 20h
sur la chaîne parlementaire assemblée
nationale
on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet c'est
donc avec nous deux experts sur ce
dossier puisqu'il faut des décisions
politiques derrière pour prendre en
compte la qualité des citoyens nous
sommes les citoyens de l'europe
c'est vraiment un élément important la
commission parlementaire c'est là que se
dessine une part importante des réformes
imagine-t-on élections en évitant un peu
différente - fc - despotisme la droite
d'anthologie
d'abord il faut des programmes de
formation tout soit la hauteur de notre
soutien parce que ça vous parle
si tu parle pas d'un événement politique
et et lyon c'est très difficile de le
faire exister
je pense que le débat sur l'insécurité
est un débat qui a
étaient présents sur d'accord en termes
d'analysé mais est ce que le sac de rome
telle ou telle que quiconque me suis-je
encore deus à venir
les moudjahidines du peuple iranien
cette organisation d'opposition la plus
organisée de la diaspora iranienne a
pour but de renverser le régime des
mollahs elle cherche à coordonner
l'opposition dans le cadre du conseil
national de la résistance iranienne
récemment leur leader maryam radjavi qui
est aussi le président du conseil a
réussi à mobiliser une dizaine de
milliers de personnes à paris
je pense que le peuple iranien sait très
bien qu
bonjour il dit la résistance iranienne
sont aux côtes